[Music]
well hello there watching the press
preview a first look then at what is on
the front pages as they come in
so coming out we'll be seeing what's
making the headlines with pippa career
political editor of the daily mirror
and harry cole political editor of the
sun great to see you both
as ever though straight to the front
pages and most of them as you might
expect
are leading on the lifting of
restrictions on july the 19th
so to the telegraph then it's now or
never their front page
echoing the prime minister's words it's
the same
take for the daily mail it's now or
never the paper says
meanwhile the financial times leads on
the lifting of restrictions despite
warnings
from scientists about the rise in the
number of covert cases
the guardian labels the move a covert 19
gamble
the metro also leads on the pm's
announcement on restrictions today with
the headline
boris rolls the dice the eye leads with
the promise of an increased
vaccination roll out as rules around
face masks are
lifted free lions keeping the football
frenzy alive the sun says the prime
minister has
torn up social distancing laws masking
for trouble that's the front of the
mirror which notes there is mounting
concerns over the
decision to scrap mandatory face
coverings
and the daily style pokes fun at dominic
cummings the prime minister's former top
aide
calling him ludicrous
anyway so pippa create harry cole are
here um so do you get a sense from those
newspapers then harry
that some of this is controversial and
that people have different views about
this or do you think most
are supportive there's a lot of gambles
thrown in there
yeah i think like lots of these things
uh the dividing line will come down on
what your view of boris johnson is and
what your view the government is
um these ten things tend to find uh a
sort of natural division at the moment
yes it is a gamble cases are going up
but we've got to remember what the
promise was
it was you know get jabs in the arms for
the most vulnerable
protect the nhs all the data at the
moment
shows that hospitalizations while
creeping up are
at a stage where even chris whittie and
patrick valens have said
are not any threat to overwhelming the
nhs so at some point
a political decision has to be made of
at what level
can we live with the virus like we do
with other diseases like we do with the
flu
not saying these these are the same
thing
but you know flu kills thousands of
people every year we don't lock down for
that
so it's you know it is a tough tough
call but someone has to make it and we
elect
our politicians to make these decisions
and when they do
um you know it's on on their head yet
but i don't think the
the sort of um i don't you you don't
have to look around the high streets and
around the shops around the pubs around
the parks
to see i think the public are slightly
voting with their feet
on restrictions and further and further
carrying things on
if you want to wear masks i think they
will but um yeah
i think it's almost sort of reflecting
of reality of you know
people are able to make a judgment for
themselves and they're going on with
their lives
and your newspaper the mirror pippa one
of those not entirely cheering
this political decision uh but do you
buy this um
daily telegraph take it's now or never
the idea that it's better to do it now
with the natural fire break of the
summer holidays which they seem to be
heavily relying on then do it in the
winter when it might be worse
well i think harry is right to say that
it's a tough call for whoever has to
make the decision
and obviously it's one that the
government has put a lot of thought
and uh obviously the scientists as well
into
i happen to think uh it would surprise
you to hear that they have
not made the right decision i think that
suggesting it's now or never
is actually disingenuous i think it's
rather
overly simplistic messaging to suggest
that there's
a binary choice between lifting all the
restrictions
all on one day or perhaps having a more
gradual approach until we get to a point
where as you rightly say anna moore's
population
is vaccinated by july the 19th we should
have
potentially two-thirds if we're lucky of
the population
um having had uh with having had their
jabs
and that's obviously fantastic but it's
not everybody there'll still be millions
of people including those who can't have
a job because they are
either clinically vulnerable um or
uh for other reasons um they they won't
be protected and of course let's not
forget children
and you know letting the virus run
rampage
through um you know the younger
generation seems to be the strategy here
uh in order to kind of like bolster herd
immunity
as an outcome for the entire population
so i don't think it's fair of the
government to say it has to be now or
never i don't think that's right i think
there are definitely merits to lifting
restrictions right now and harry's right
people are fed up
with uh living their lives by by these
strict rules but i don't think you have
to do it all now
in one big bang which frankly feels like
a big gamble
yes and indeed that is the theme from
the metro and a number of the newspapers
boris rolls the dice
just on that specific point that pippa
made there allowing this to run rampage
through younger people
effectively herd immunity by the back
door it stops the jcvi having to make
that
really controversial decision about
whether to vaccinate the under 18s
is that what we're saying here harry no
absolutely not
the jvci are going to make that decision
regardless of of any lockdown and this
is you know this is about longer
than just the summer it's about next
winter it's about next year it's about
booster jabs you know this
this ain't over this is gonna rumble on
for a very long time
and the idea that's that you know
allowing kids to stay in school was
letting the virus run run but rap run
rampant sorry try saying that with a
uh after a long day um you know
the damage of kids not being in school
is far greater than the risk they have
of
of the virus or indeed the risk they
have of spreading it back to their
vaccinated mostly mostly vaccinated
parents
um so look it is a tough call but the
point that people was making that we
shouldn't just have a big bang lift off
in one day we haven't
this has been a phased we know we've
been talking about this
damn road map for so long since march
you know it began on march the 8th
the big bang actually if we were if
we're honest was
uh in april um and then may that you
know getting pubs and restaurants and
shops to reopen
that was you know the real sort of i
think big
big jump and actually the the fear
sort of surge in the virus didn't
actually happen at that point um yeah
they were told
we were told the the cases were going to
go up at every single stage of this
unlocking
and actually that just didn't happen
this has been a phased unlocking
and actually the difference between
where we are now
give or take a few stadiums of where
people are going to be probably being
tested or
have to be double jab to enter anyway is
actually
i think not quite you know it's not
quite the leap that but people think it
is
i mean i guess the problem is we've got
this delta variant
we know it's a trixie one we're on a
nine day doubling time
if you look at the coronavirus map of
the uk the interactive one
cases really are soaring in many places
and this idea of personal responsibility
which is
writ all over your newspaper the sun if
we have a look at that three lines and
the
and the thumbs up from the prime
minister is that really this isn't
it's first of all an abdication of your
own decision making by government
and secondly that it's not just up to
you what you do because what you do
affects other people and there are
people out there for whom this means
you stay at home again because you're
scared
i i i think that these two things aren't
aren't aren't separate issues you can be
responsible for your own safety and
response for other people
no one is stopping you from wearing a
mask but you know do you really want to
live in a society
where you'll find six thousand five
hundred pounds for breaking a rule just
by getting on a train
i don't i don't want that to last
forever i want that to be gone as soon
as possible
and you say that the case rates are
going up cases yes are going up but
crucially the promise
the promise that we were given is
protect the nhs
stop the nhs from falling over it
doesn't matter if cases go up
if people are vaccinated in a vaccinated
population because those graphs
go on the dashboard today look at the
graphs that were used in that press
conference today
cases are going up deaths are flatlining
and hospitalizations are creeping up
at a level if you compare to the where
we were in the foothills of the
of the second wave it is a vastly
different scene
there is no threat to the nhs being
overwhelmed and that was the promise
you know we stayed at home to protect
the nhs the nhs is not
under threat now we should be allowed to
carry on with our lives
seven day average deaths is uh 18
uh which is vastly different as harry
says from january and february
pippa uh if we take a look at the
guardian
uh johnson sweeps away lockdown
restrictions again that word
gamble in a covert 19 gamble and the
paper going on to suggest that
the plan changes make england an outlier
in much of the rest of the world where
restrictions remain
to combat infections um you know it is
now the right
time is the question and if we don't do
it
what happens come the autumn when when
kids go back to school and universities
return
well i think that um i mean the
guardian's suggesting that we're going
to be the most unrestricted society in
europe we also of course have one of the
highest vaccination rates in europe so
that shouldn't be
that shouldn't be disregarded um but
um you know i mean harry is talking
about
the incremental changes as we've as
we've come out of the roads map
i guess really the big one here that a
lot of people will be concerned by
is face masks because while the
government says that it's down to
personal responsibility
actually it's very difficult for people
to choose
what risk they want to take when it's
actually other people's masks that are
going to be protecting them and i
thought it was a very telling moment
in the press conference earlier when
boris johnson was asked whether he would
wear a mask
and he said well it depends on the
circumstances and it's all about
personal responsibility
and then the same question was asked to
chris witty who said that actually it's
the wearing one is the thing we can do
to protect one another and that it's
about common courtesy and then suddenly
boris johnson sort of interjected and
said well
yes absolutely quite right i'm obviously
going to wear one in crowded places and
simple courtesy is that that hasn't been
his instinctive reaction and that was
very telling to me you know this is a
real
this is a prime minister who um at his
heart
is a libertarian that doesn't like
telling people what to do and doesn't
like imposing rules we've seen that
throughout the pandemic
throughout he struggled with bringing in
lockdowns and so on and so his instinct
particularly now he's backed up with
by a health secretary in sanji javid at
the same
bend as opposed to matt hancock i think
probably was a bit more sort of cautious
and
and you know probably did put sort of
the data the data first and listen to
the scientists
he's now in a position where um you know
he's free to
sort of you know make decisions based
entirely on on his own judgments about
personal responsibility and it's a very
definite shift in tone
absolutely well after the break we will
talk more about face masks here what you
think about that as well
harry and on the two elements that we
wait to hear more about which is
what happens in schools and what happens
in terms of travel as well
two big issues that we'll come back with
after this break
[Music]
all the things we buy the food we eat
fueling the loss of nature
and also increasing the risk of climate
change so clearly something has to be
done
so we're calling for you know a
three-quarter slashing of our footprint
let's remember this is
just what's happening in the uk it's
also called
factors in the things we import from
overseas as well the food we bring from
overseas the clothes the cars and so on
but what the report also says is
basically speaking there's a lot of
flexibility in the system we can make
those
changes there's really substantial
changes without massively impacting our
lives so don't forget the government has
already committed to a 78
reduction in greenhouse gases so these
things are perfectly doable
and actually the economy could benefit
as a result as well so in this country
it might be surprised to hear that
we we waste about 10 million tons of
food and drink
every single year 10 million tons so
just think about what it costs to
produce in terms of time
resources you know processing transport
and so on
so that's horrifying that we we waste 10
billion tons
but 70 of that is perfectly edible so if
we could kind of
rework the system so that we're not kind
of throwing this stuff away
and of course that 30 percent is not
edible for us
is edible for plenty of other things for
example insects and they're really good
systems
up and running already to take food
waste
feed it to insects and then we feed
those insects to chickens
rather than giving them soy which came
from latin america
and it was produced by cutting down
rainforest and clearing grasslands and
so on so there's a real
win-win situation so i think the the
images you're showing here
show us the impacts i mean only these
last couple of years we've seen just
extraordinary outbursts of you know
fires around the world you know
the horrible fires we're seeing in
british columbia at the moment cyprus i
saw yesterday but yeah
siberia amazon australia we're seeing
these extreme weather events they
those will become the norms sadly and we
know that we're losing species around
the world as well and
don't forget since 1900 if 500 types of
vertebrates have gone extinct so these
are animals
no one will ever see again and that
those risks will increase
as if we don't take action now
this monastery is under the protections
of russian peacekeepers
i'm diana magnay and i'm sky's russia
correspondent based here in moscow
they can't arrest everybody
[Music]
i'm coming from a family of fishermen
actually my family have been fishermen
for five generations
the fishermen cut displaced by accident
so we give them the motivation
and the system to bring back to the land
we have collected already more than
110 000 kilos of plastic from the bottom
of the sea
[Music]
a few years ago my partner alex and i
realized that there was a huge issue
with the way cleaning products were
being sold
[Music]
the family could only be bought in
plastic bottles and once used these
cheap bottles would inevitably break and
end up in landfill
since launching we've so far saved over
ten thousand plastic spray bottles
from ending up in landfill
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me our paper career
political editor of the daily mirror
and harry cole political editor of the
sun welcome back to both of you
i'm gonna go straight to the mat cartoon
if you will uh oblige me
uh brief encounter they say on the train
it's over between us
now i've seen you without your mask i'm
not so keen uh well
it's a brilliant take isn't it of of
many of the newspapers who are picking
up on this
critical face mask issue pippa you you
had your thoughts before the break
harry um love them we'll load them wait
to get rid of them what's your thought
yeah look
it is completely you know i load them
but um as we were arguing behind the
scenes should we say i would i would
wear one
without the six and a half thousand quid
fine i'm sure others
perhaps wouldn't it's been a it's become
a talker it's the it's the it's the very
easy dividing line
i have a horrible feeling it's going to
become the new lead versus remain of do
you wear a mask
uh after um after july 19th
um i think five minutes was actually
what's a little bit more nuanced than um
perhaps
uh uh some papers are given in credit
for tomorrow
he did make this he uses this example of
you know
would you wear a mask on a crowded tube
train yes
but should he be criminalized for should
people be criminalized if you're the
only person in the carriage
uh on the last train home you know
should you be
facing a fine for not wearing a mask
then and you know
you walk past a crowded you know often
like round parliament for example where
people and i are based you know if
you're walking through big crowds
outside who are gathered not
often to protest these things you know
you put your mask on if you're
you know if you're sitting in the office
by yourself do you really need to that i
mean
there is an element of personal judgment
that's needed on these things i just
think
there can be a gray area on this we are
you know a sophisticated democracy
we are a you know an intelligent
community we we can make these judgments
for ourselves
and the idea that either the law must be
wear a mask
or face a fine you know we don't i don't
want that to carry on you know and we
were talking earlier before the break
about
you know boris johnson being this
libertarian who struggles with all these
great dictats
i want our leaders whoever they are of
whatever stripe to feel awful
to struggle about doing these things i
really want them to wrestle
with you know with with these big
decisions and not
infringe on our liberties any longer a
day longer
than they need to and i think it's quite
refreshing that government want to back
off because
you know frankly it's been a horrible
horrific awful year
where the government is way overstepped
any any government in modern times
certainly in peacetime
um and you know i want a government to
be washing their hands of that
of of those orders as quickly as
possible because it's a very slippery
slope
if they don't yeah we've only got one
minute left just very quickly then your
paper uh the mirror pippa
masking for trouble is your take on this
controversial of all elements the eye
two double jabs pushes
masks rulers lifted and very quickly
what did the public
feel about this i mean are people
genuinely divided
i think people it's not the 50 52 48
brexit divide that harry suggests it
might become
ultimately people are protected by other
people's masks which is why the personal
responsibility element is a problem
is an issue there's a yougov poll today
which suggested that 71
of people want mosques to remain
compulsory not forever
but until such a point that more of the
population is vaccinated and that's on
public transport slightly if you're
in shop 66 but still an overwhelming
majority of the public back then
hopefully that'll translate into people
actually wearing them but i sadly as
somebody who regularly travels on the
tube
buses and and trains um i think that
without the pressure of uh the legal
enforcement
legal threat of the fine lots of people
just won't bother
pippa harry thank you and i know you'll
be staying with us for the next part of
our program which starts in a few
minutes time
now let's take a look though at the
weather